all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with secret Invasion
and we are wrapping it up in this video
now we're gonna wrap up some of the
loose plot threads because Bendis
handles those pretty quickly and then we
kind of get into how all this unfolds
and it actually leads into one of the
best branding initiatives that Marvel
Comics had done really up to that point
in quite some time so what we end up
doing here is we initially pick up with
Deadpool right now as you guys know
Deadpool in the last video that we
talked about had basically joined the
Scrolls quote unquote what we're gonna
end up finding out is this is just a
giant ruse that what Deadpool does is
the kind of pitches himself to the
Scrolls in the sense that he's a guy
who's always kind of been cast out from
the superhero community and in that way
it's true right that's an actual
accurate statement by Deadpool the
superhero Community had never really
taken him that seriously at all and so
as a kind of cast out himself he wanted
to basically end the entirety of the
Earth's population or at least that's
how he pitched himself right he was
siding with the Scrolls and so what he
ends up doing is effectively telling
them that because he is so unique
regarding his healing Factor where the
scrolls are initially going to take him
out and then just copy his healing
factor and call it a day his response is
but like they don't they don't know how
to fight like I fight right it's one
thing to have my healing Factor but at
that point you're just throwing an
endless number of Scrolls at the
superheroes in the hopes that you can
somehow defeat them whereas if I can
train your scroll soldiers how to fight
once they have my healing Factor you can
do whatever you want with me but in
effect you won't have to kill so many of
your own kind and that's one of the
things to keep in mind while the Scrolls
do see this as a wartime campaign and
while they are willing to make
sacrifices to achieve their goal they're
not willing to throw lives away we're
going you know in order to to have it
done right they're not Russia during
World War II they're not killing
retreating soldiers and so as a result
of this Deadpool literally takes those
Scrolls who have been given his healing
factor and starts training them how to
fight but as you guys know Deadpool's
crazy as hell so not only does he teach
them how to fight he also basically
turns them into crazy people now
initially the Scrolls don't quite know
what to make of this and they're kind of
like I mean
these guys going nuts like this are they
supposed to be doing that and it's like
well we have to trust Deadpool right we
have to trust that this guy knows what
he's doing that he knows what he's
talking about the funny thing about this
is that as time goes on he basically
gets these guys to a point where they
all literally start killing each other
right like all these Scrolls soldiers
that have been given Deadpool's healing
Factor all basically just start taking
each other out and the reason why this
matters is because one Deadpool had
basically had these weapons retrofitted
so these guys could be destroyed if they
needed to be but the second thing behind
this is that this is all a ploy right
this is all a ruse the whole purpose
behind Deadpool doing this was to gain
the trust of the Scrolls to get inside
their ship so he could feed information
and he's giving us information to Nick
Fury now I told you guys at the very
beginning of secret Invasion when we
cover this and as always you'll find a
link to the playlist down in the
description so you can get caught up
that what Nick Fury had been doing was
secretly operating behind the scenes in
order to secure every bit of information
he could heard from every Source he
could and so that's exactly what's going
on here now as for what's going on back
on Earth and actually in the satellite
itself we switch over to Abigail brand
now remember Abigail brand is the leader
of Sword which is basically Shield
except they monitor space and where
their space station was like one of the
first things to be taken out by the
Scrolls that way Humanity was blinded in
terms of what was going on out in space
which of course allowed the scroll
forces to basically properly invade that
Abigail brand had also learned that Reed
Richards of the Fantastic Four had been
taken by the Scrolls now a lot of that
was done just because of the fact that
when it came to the Scrolls themselves
Reed Richards his intelligence is
universally recognized he's largely
basically seen as the smartest person in
the universe so having his knowledge at
their disposal and really kind of
tormenting and torturing him due to the
fact that he was part of the original
Illuminati that having him there is a
huge asset for the Empire with Abigail
brand basically being the leader of
sword and then freeing Reed Richards
they end up basically transporting back
to Earth and then of course we
transition over to Maria Hill whose
Helicarrier was taken down by the scroll
forces and ultimately ambushed by Jarvis
who's normally The Avengers Butler but
turned out to be a scroll now one of the
things that she was told early on by
Nick Fury of course again if you guys
recall when the two of them had met that
Nick Fury had said make sure you get
some life model decoys you're surrounded
by nothing but enemies you just don't
know it yet Maria Hill despite the fact
that she is exceedingly arrogant in
Marvel Comics despite the fact that she
usually always believes she's right and
can never really admit when she's wrong
ultimately ended up going with the
information Nick Fury gave her because
if Nick Fury is nothing it's usually
always correct and so as a result of
that she basically got a life model
decoy and so when Jarvis and his forces
open up on Maria Hill when they open
fire on her it's of course a life model
decoy they destroy which allows the real
Maria Hill to basically take off and so
what we end up doing is kind of joining
the rest of the superheroes on Earth and
basically the the conclusion of the
secret Invasion event at least the
proper conclusion to this event right so
switching over to Deadpool what ends up
happening here is of course Deadpool
with all these forces being taken out
the initial intention of the Scrolls is
to locate and find Deadpool they end up
sitting super Scroll after him of course
Deadpool takes that guy out pretty
easily I mean that's one of the things
to know is that at the end of the day
Deadpool's easily able to overcome those
guys because when it comes to the super
scroll he's just an amalgamation of the
earth superhero Powers right Deadpool's
face off against those guys multiple
times so he knows how to basically
overcome all of them and so what this
does is he basically ends up leading
what's left of these scroll soldiers who
have all started mutating and everything
now and literally destroys the
Deadpool's Scrolls right as well as
what's left of the scroll forces
following that he ends up taking
information that would be Paramount to
destroying the secret Invasion Fleet
right the squirrel Fleet and he
essentially teleports it or sends it to
Nick Fury the crazy thing about this is
that while this is bio data right that
can basically kill will kill the scroll
Queen when the information sent it's
supposed to go to Nick Fury but instead
it's intercepted by Norman Osborne now
that's why I told you guys when we
covered the Thunderbolt story Norman
Osborne was going to be the single most
important character in this story or at
least one of the most important
characters in this whole story because
it's this action right here that
basically changes everything right so
what we end up doing is switching back
to Earth when the Scrolls basically make
their statement to the World At Large
and it's really cool because what they
say here is as you know your Global
communication systems are fully restored
we apologize for the inconvenience of
taking them down this is a time for
unheralded transition for your world as
it becomes part of the scroll Empire for
those of you who are understandably
confused and panicked let me explain it
to you very clearly your lives will go
on as they were you get to keep your
homes your culture your family your jobs
we are not taking anything away from you
we're only adding things you'll notice
that those scroll Empire has made no
offensive moves towards your armies or
your governments we have only defended
ourselves when necessary and we request
that all armed forces ignore whatever
orders you've received from your
Superior officers and stand down now
this is a very important thing on a
variety of different levels what Brian
Michael Bendis is doing here is actually
drawing on the superhero's perception
and really the world's perception
following a story called maximum
security so maximum security was a story
that was written in Marvel Comics back
in the 90s I think and the whole idea
behind this is that the the cree race
had actually taken over Earth and turned
it into a prison planet and in fact Ron
and the accuser was basically the warden
of Earth at that point in time meaning
Humanity has been down this road before
and so when the Scrolls show up here and
it's like hey hey guys we're here we're
on your side we're not going to take
anything away from you yada yada what
they're in effect saying here is that
we're not going to do what the cree did
during maximum security we're not not
going to turn you into prisoners your
lives will continue on the way they
always had you won't really notice a
discernible difference here now the
other part of this is the scrolls are
lying right they're literally asking
soldiers to basically ignore orders from
their Superior officers which would make
it easier for the Scrolls to basically
take them all out but it's also a very
very smart maneuver because of what use
is a military officer if he's surrounded
by soldiers that won't obey his orders
but following Reed Richards basically
arriving at the Savage land with Abigail
brand at this point with Reed Richard's
arrival because he's been stuck on the
scroll ship all this time once he's here
they're able to tell pretty fast that is
actually read and following that he
literally galvanizes the superheroes and
brings them together now a lot of that's
because one of the things to remember is
the Fantastic Four is like the first
family of Marvel Comics so in a lot of
ways even though the Fantastic Four
don't usually get involved in the
traditional superhero Antics meaning
they're not facing off against like
Thanos or something like that they're
usually out exploring things a lot of
that's because they've done their dirt
quote unquote right they fought their
share of bad guys and they've done their
thing they've kind of moved beyond that
right they've been promoted to a
managerial position it's the best
analogy that I can make and so with that
in mind read Richards is highly
respected by the superhero Community
which is why they listen to him right
that and his level of intelligence and
so on but the other part of this is
again Tony Stark's struggling now
there's what Tony Stark struggles with
publicly then there's what Tony Stark
struggles with privately publicly people
are just kind of like you know his
statement to people is start Tech is
down and this and this and that and that
and so on and so forth what he actually
struggles with on a more private level
is that the world's going to see him as
a failure because remember at this point
in time in Marvel Comics this takes
place after Civil War which means Tony
Stark is the director of Shield all this
happened under his watch and the world
is going to ask the question why and
when that question does get asked he's
ultimately going to end up losing his
position he knows that and in fact we
know that and so what's really cool
about this is you kind of have people
responding right the average person
responding in a couple different ways
some actually side with the Scrolls
right if Humanity could get it together
Humanity would have already gotten it
together like the fact that Humanity
just hasn't gotten it together yet means
Humanity doesn't want to so if he if the
human race won't change then someone
needs to force the human race to change
and the scrolls are doing that and so is
that a good thing because the the the
cost of that is that the world would be
basically turned into a prison planet so
again this presents some really
interesting philosophical arguments to
how this kind of situation can be
approached but the reality is that it's
the superheroes facing off against the
Scrolls which is one of the reasons why
I always love this story because one of
the ideas that I've always put out there
is that superheroes don't really exist
to like make the world better
superheroes exist to maintain the status
quo right you could argue superheroes
are actually the bad guys so it's really
interesting you know in terms of how
things function but nonetheless what
this does is this actually coincides
with the return of Thor now here's a
thing to understand about this right one
of the things to know is that not only
is Thor here but you also have Bucky
Captain America so secret invasion was
one of those stories that Marvel wrote
where it was kind of a transitionary
story think of it as one of many that
Marvel was writing at the time they were
like the equivalent of Empire Strikes
Back in the Star Wars Mythos right that
this was a story that was designed to
one properly introduce us or really have
us see the real and new Bucky Barnes
Captain America he did get his own solo
comic for a time but Steve Rogers was
killed he was assassinated by by agent
13 Sharon Carter who had basically been
duped right she was more or less being
hypnotized when it was done by The Red
Skull and his forces so Bucky Barnes
ended up taking up the mantle and Bucky
Barnes became the new Captain America
but the other part about this is that
during the events of Thor disassembled
or Thor Ragnarok as is colloquially
known by fans that that was the death of
Thor right during the events of Civil
War Tony Stark had cloned Thor and
that's where you got the Ragnarok cyborg
version but this version you see here is
the one that returned during J Michael
strzinski's run he's been traveling
around Earth and basically waking up the
Asgardian Spirits or the Essences of the
various asgardians who were who have
basically been reborn in human form and
then bringing them to Asgard which he
had rebuilt in Broxton Oklahoma and so
that's kind of been his thing for a
little bit now and this actually takes
place after the events of basically Thor
beating the hell out of Iron Man if you
guys never saw that it was just an
amazing moment I'm pretty sure we did a
video on it it was really really cool
but the thing about this is that it's
kind of the superheroes returning to a
degree right kind of stepping back into
the normal landscape and so again what
you end up getting here is just a great
big huge massive battle that takes place
between the scroll forces and Earth
superheroes pretty straightforward not a
whole lot doing here it's one of the
things that I hope you guys notice is
that the Marvel Cinematic Universe very
much models the form and function of its
movies after the way that Marvel Comics
writes their comic books right like
here's the exposition here's what's
going on now time for the big battle
which is always the same no matter what
movie you're watching right it's that
kind of a thing right it's the way it
works and honestly it's a multi-billion
dollar franchise who's to argue against
that although I do think it's time for
the MCU to start changing and I'll make
a video on that you know on uh on my
video essays on geek culture explained
which will be coming at some point in
the future no I haven't abandoned that
channel so here's the thing right with
this massive battle is taking place here
it's pretty straightforward again it's
Heroes fighting Scrolls and that's
really more or less it right just kind
of a battle between these characters and
really things are pretty straightforward
the big thing about this is remember
Jessica Drew is the scroll Queen it's
the person she chose to be we covered
that in the last video that the scroll
Queen chose Jessica Drew because of her
kind of time basically gravitating
around the superhero landscape she's
friends with Spider-Man she's been a
part of the Avengers she is a social
appreciated with the X-Men even if she's
not the closest person to them she's
been a an agent that's worked with Hydra
she literally has had her hands in
everything so to basically take control
of her or to replace her means to have
access to the entirety of really the
superhero and even super villain
landscape in Marvel Comics now of course
as is always when it comes to stuff like
this you have the Watcher who appears
because you know in the mid-2000s The
Watcher always showed up it was like oh
this is this event is going to be a big
event and everything's going to change
because of this it was it stopped
mattering after a while which is always
kind of disappointing but as the battle
rages on and the Earth superheroes were
able to overcome the forces of the
Scrolls at least in terms of this battle
basically the scroll Queen is the only
one left but she refuses to give ground
because she's a religious believer she's
driven by religious convictions she
truly believes that Earth is the
rightful place of the scroll Empire
following the almost complete
destruction of their race during
Annihilation and the destruction of
their Homeworld by Galactus and so so
because she's driven by such convictions
she refuses to give ground so this
ultimately leads to Wolverine launching
an attack with the attention of killing
her but she's killed before that happens
and it's done by Norman Osborne because
Norman is the one who intercepts the
information from Deadpool that the
scroll Queen is the one you have to
assassinate and here's the person that
she is she's Jessica Drew that's the
whole reason why Norman Osborne even
sent the Thunderbolts into this battle
in the first place under any normal
circumstance Norman Osborne wouldn't
really care and in fact he would sit
back and wait to see which side he
should choose based on which side is
most likely to win if the Earth
superheroes are most likely to win it's
hey guys the Thunderbolts are here to
help I mean we're no we're not going to
change the tide but like we have to do
something here right we've just been
dealing with our own major crisis or if
the Scrolls were winning then it's just
like hey Scrolls I'm the guy you want on
your side right like that kind of a
thing now the other part of this is that
because this battle was so highly
televised the whole world sees Norman
Osborne taking this killing blow which
means that as far as everybody is
concerned Norman Osborne is the one who
ended the threat now that's immensely
important here because what we end up
finding out is that without the scroll
Queen and without any kind of a superior
officer no one knows who to take their
orders from and so literally the whole
scroll not really the race but those
individuals who are here they kind of
fall into disarray and disorganization
which is long enough for those
superheroes that can operate in space
Thor and Captain Marvel and those guys
to basically take out the scroll forces
that are out there and so once the dust
settles and everything is all cleared up
it basically leads to Tony Stark a
literally destroying pretty much all of
the ships out there except for one and
the reason why is because on that ship
are the superheroes that were replaced
with scroll duplicates that's kind of in
the question that a lot of you guys have
been asking you've got you've basically
been wondering if the Scrolls have
replaced superheroes what happened to
the original superheroes they basically
they just kind of been sitting on a ship
this is kind of a Brian Michael benda's
hand wavy explanation right like I mean
why because literally in the comic the
questions asked why didn't the Scrolls
just kill them after they duplicated
them and it's like well they they
probably needed them for genetic
material in case you know they could
somehow increase their abilities or
something like that it's literally
Marvel just kind of hand waving the
explanation away but the fact is all
these different superheroes have all
essentially returned and so that's when
the discussion starts to be had where do
we go from here how does everybody pick
up these pieces how does it all make
sense and one of the things that we find
out here is that because Tony Stark had
failed because Tony Stark had never seen
the secret Invasion coming that what the
US government literally did was stand
against Tony Stark they kicked him out
as director of Shield right they were
like you were literally you had all the
world's intelligence at your disposal
right you're the one that said after
Civil War that you could keep us safe
that you could protect us from the
various threats of the world the first
threat we get which is this the Scrolls
secretly replacing superheroes you miss
right you are a terrible director of
Shield they kick him out and they
replace them with Norman Osborne now a
lot of you guys are probably asking how
could Norman Osborne be replaced the
reality here is that the government is
really more about public perception than
anything else and as far as the world is
concerned Norman Osborne saved the day
you combined that with Norman Osborne's
nickel slick smile and his silver tongue
and there's literally no question that
this guy could weasel his way in the
funny thing about this is that as soon
as Norman Osborne is made the new
director of shield and he's basically
given Avengers Tower right they hand it
to him this guy runs in Avengers tower
now as soon as it's handed over to him
he goes into an elevator he goes to an
underground bunker he meets with Namor
the Submariner Mephisto Loki who's a
chick now Emma Frost from the hellfire
club kind of the X-Men she's kind of a
good guy bad guy and Doctor Doom forming
his own cabal and basically initiating
the events of dark rain and dark rain
was great oh my God I loved dark rain
it's literally like dark rain for those
of you guys who don't know it's not
really a story arc it's not like dark
rain part one part two part three it's
more like dark Avengers dark X-Men stuff
like that but it's basically Norman
Osborne's attempt to use the forces of
Shield to conquer the world it's awesome
it's just it's one of the coolest
stories that Marvel had written for a
long long time but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
Bruce
[Music]